always going on how old are these young
guys take to [ __ ] film what's this
thing called again the hot ones sounds
like a [ __ ] movie from the 70s
[ __ ] slow let's go it's only your
[ __ ] wing it's about an inch and a
half long with a [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
sauce so this is how you make the wings
are you [ __ ] kidding me
excuse me that's it show me those
[ __ ] things they're dry
how many weeks did you cook them for
they're [ __ ] disgusting there's me
thinking is a properly cooked [ __ ]
chicken wing this is the worst kitchen
in America where's the milk that's the
milk
really the milks [ __ ] sour Jesus
Christ we don't even get a fresh meal
this is how you plate food it's like a
[ __ ] cricket bat from the [ __ ]
17th century you idiot who did your
research I [ __ ] monkey with a
typewriter are you that [ __ ] I did a
deep dive on your [ __ ] Instagram
what's wrong with you can you grow a
pair ice-cold milk can I make it any
[ __ ] clearer that means chill milk
it's [ __ ] boiling you Muppets get
government
get Gordon Ramsay get [ __ ] golden
Ramsay wake up Sean let's go
[Music]
[Music]